creuser des tranchées pour se protéger
et faire face à l'invasion russe à Kiev
ces hommes et ces femmes sont tous
volontaires et prêts à libre et bataille
je pense que nous allons gagner même si
ça sera difficile nous allons les briser
pour que leurs enfants et petits-enfants
s'en souviennent à jamais
la menace d'une attaque plane sur la
capitale la saut Paris imminent des
troupes et des blindés russes sont
postés à peine à une vingtaine de
kilomètres pour défendre leur ville des
milliers de civils se sont mobilisés à
ce point d'entrée de Kiev les habitants
du quartier contrôlent les entrées et
sorties des véhicules notre
otage principal est de nous assurer que
les équipements de nos militaires de nos
services spéciaux passent normalement
sans problème les gens sont positifs
tout le monde prend la victoire
sont armés et on rejoint l'unité de
défense territoriale ukrainienne on y
retrouve d'anciens avocats des
commerçants des chauffeurs des hommes
qui n'avaient aucune espérance militaire
avant l'invasion russe de l'Ukraine
quelle est ma motivation qui d'autre va
le faire pourquoi les citoyens d'un
autre pays le feraient pour moi
est-ce que quelqu'un va le faire
personne ne peut le faire à la place des
habitants et des citoyens de l'Ukraine
l'armée russe aura fort à faire face à
une population prête à défendre Kiev
coûte que coûte le maire Vladimir clitco
a prévenu que le conflit ferait beaucoup
de victimes mais il a juré que les
Ukrainiens ne se rendrait jamais